ich rufe auf die tagesordnungspunkte 7a
bis 7 c sowie zusatzpunkt zwei jeweils
erste beratung der von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwürfe zu sofortmaßnahmen für
einen beschleunigten ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und weiterer
maßnahmen im stromsektor zur änderung
des windenergie auf see gesetzes und
anderer vorschriften
sowie zur änderung des
energiewirtschaftsgesetzes
sofortprogramm und zur anpassung im
recht der endkunden belieferung und
erste beratung des von den fraktionen
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
eingebrachten gesetzentwurfs zur
beschleunigung des einsatzes
verflüssigten erdgases
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten beschlossen ich eröffne
hiermit die aussprache das wort hat der
bundesminister dr robert habeck
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
guten morgen lassen sie mich kurz mit
einem aktuellen ereignis anfang des dann
abend ungefähr 22 30 hat putin ein
dekret veröffentlicht wonach europäische
gasversorger jetzt von russland
sanktioniert werden in deutschland ist
gazprom und ihre töchter betroffen das
heißt einige der tochterunternehmen
bekommen jetzt kein gas mehr aus
russland
aber der markt bietet andere
alternativen sie versorgen sich auf dem
markt mit anderen gas vier monitoren die
situation genau wir haben uns auf
situation vorbereitet und ich werde sie
dann im lauf des tages beziehungsweise
die bundesnetzagentur
informieren aber die situation ist so
dass der gasmarkt den gasaustritt aus
russland kommt kompensieren kann sehr
geehrte damen und herren ist zeigt also
dass die auseinandersetzung um energie
eine waffe ist und dass energie in einem
wirtschafts konflikt hart eingesetzt
werden kann insofern sind all die
anstrengungen die wir im moment
unternehmen und unternehmen müssen um
die versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
zu gewährleisten nicht das gegenteil
dessen was wir jetzt gleich diskutieren
sondern die voraussetzung dafür dass wir
in zukunft energie sicher sind ist der
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien das
sind 1
direkte
es gibt eine direkte linie von dem
abschied von fossilen energien aus
russland hin zum abschied ja von
fossilen energien insgesamt und das
bedeutet ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien das vorgelegte paket ist die
größte energiemarkt reform seit jahren
ich würde sagen seit jahrzehnten es ist
ein paket das verschiedene gesetze
zusammen nimmt das wichtigste und das
größte ist das aber auch dass wind auf
sie gesetzt und die mwg novelle gehören
dazu es ist eine fundamentale
neuausrichtung des gesamten energie
sektors auf treibhaus neutralität und
auch die ist dringend geboten bei allem
was uns in europa und in deutschland im
moment mit blick auf die russischen
lieferungen bedrückt wir dürfen den
blick auf den großen horizont nicht
verlieren die un hat vor einigen tagen
gesagt dass mit einer großen
wahrscheinlichkeit in den nächsten fünf
jahren das 15 grad ziel überschritten
wird vielleicht noch nicht dauerhaft
aber dieses vielleicht hängt ganz
maßgeblich vom menschlichen tunap von
politischen entscheidungen dh die zeit
läuft uns davon sie läuft uns
buchstäblich davon und der krieg und die
toten im krieg in der ukraine das ist
schlimm und das ist furchtbar aber sie
werden mitbekommen haben dass an anderen
stellen der erde ernteausfälle hungernot
katastrophen drohen weil die tiere sich
in einem dramatischen ausmaß erhitzt wir
haben die chance dagegen an zu arbeiten
und wir tun ist mit diesem gesetzespaket
das wir heute vorlegen
das gesetzespaket setzt die ziele die
die alte bundesregierung schon
beschlossen hat um in konkrete maßnahmen
und die diese bundesregierung übernommen
hat wir werden die
treibhausgasemissionen damit 2030 um 65
prozent sinken und 2040 und - 80% wir
werden die stromerzeugung erneuerbare
energien damit 2030 auf 80 prozent auf
80 prozent anheben und dann in der mitte
der 30er jahre im strombereich die
treibhaus neutralität erreichen können
wir richten den netzausbau entsprechend
auf diese anforderung neu aus wir heben
die ausschreibungen aufwinden wind auf
see also offshore wir nutzen dafür neue
instrumente instrumente die noch nicht
ausgewiesene flächen ebenfalls in die
ausschreibung gegeben so dass damit dann
die industrie die chance hat diesen
windstrom auch für die produktion von
wasserstoff verstärkt zu nutzen wir
sorgen außerdem dafür dass die
beteiligung der menschen in diesem land
an den erneuerbaren energien deutlich
gesteigert wird bürgerwindparks eigenen
stromverbrauch die möglichkeit der
kommunen an den windparks zu profitieren
all das wird deutlich angegeben so dass
die demokratisierung des energiesystems
die teilhabe der menschen am
energiesystem tatsächlich nochmal
deutlich angehoben und erweitert wird
bis an die grenze des möglichen und wo
ich das
und wo ich die
zwischenrufe hier von ganz rechts höre
sie werden sie werden möglicherweise
höheren überschuss interessant sie
werden vielleicht mitbekommen haben dass
gestern ein schwedisches unternehmen
oswald eine investitionsentscheidung von
4,5 milliarden zur batterieproduktion in
deutschland getroffen hat dieses
unternehmen hat europaweit gesucht wo
ist der beste standort und sie haben
sich für einen standort entschieden der
die höchste durchdringung mit
erneuerbaren energien hat sie haben sich
europaweit für den standort entschieden
wo die meisten erneuerbare energien
verfügbar sind das zeigt dass wir nicht
nur das klima schützen dass wir nicht
nur außen und sicherheitspolitische
souveränität gewinnen sondern wohlstand
und wertschöpfung arbeitsplätze und die
industrie der zukunft jetzt aufbauen wir
schaffen damit auch die zukunft für den
wohlstand in diesem land alles spricht
dafür mit großer geschwindigkeit mit
großer entschlossenheit jetzt den ausbau
der erneuerbaren und die
klimaneutralität umzusetzen spielen da
euro beteiligt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
zu den drei gesetzentwürfen der
bundesregierung die hier heute zum
ersten mal beraten werden eben legen es
geht darum erneuerbaren energien
erneuerbare energien schneller
auszubauen als das bislang in der fall
gewesen ist erster redner in der debatte
dazu jetzt andreas jung aus der unions
kollegen seitens der unions fraktion
geführt werden wir aus überzeugen und
mit nachdruck das ziel eines
beschleunigten ausbaus der erneuerbaren
energien es ist eine notwendige antwort
auf die klimakrise und es macht uns
unabhängiger von fossilen importen aus
russland da muss jetzt beherzt
vorangegangen werden energisch voran das
ist unsere linie in diesen beratungen es
geht uns dabei darum das was wir hier
tun in einen europäischen kontext zu
bringen auch mit globalen energie- und
thema partnerschaften voran zu bringen
das beherzte handeln hier in deutschland
und es bekenntnis zum internationalen
klimaschutz sind zwei seiten einer
medaille wir sollten immer im kopf haben
das was wir hier machen muss innovativ
sein muss welt fähig sein muss dazu
angelegt sein dass wir mit partnern
gemeinsam klimaschutz eine nachhaltige
energieversorgung voranbringen das ist
unser maßstab
der minister habe ich sie haben ein
umfassendes paket vorgelegt
das ziel hemmnisse abzubauen
unterstützen wir wir stellen aber fest
viel papier führt nicht automatisch zu
schnellen fortschritten wir stellen fest
dass sie einen starken schwerpunkt
setzen auf für sonnenenergie- und wind
das teilen wir die werden einen
wichtigen die werden den größten beitrag
leisten wir stellen aber auch fest dass
es in ihrem entwurf bei geothermie bei
biomasse und wasserkraft regelung gibt
die die potenziale auch dieser
erneuerbaren energien nicht ausnutzen
und deshalb ist unser anspruch in den
beratungen dazu kommen dass die
potenziale aller erneuerbaren energien
ausgeschöpft werden das bestehende
hemmnisse abgebaut werden und dass nicht
neue hürden eingezogen werden das nehmen
wir aber bei dieser vorlage war das ist
die grundsätzliche linie und dann will
ich ganz konkret sagen wo sind diese
hemmnisse wie sehen wir diese hemmnisse
es soll aus gründen die wir nicht
nachvollziehen können eine deckelung
geben zur einspeisung von biomethan in
kraft-wärme-kopplungsanlagen da bitte
ich die vertreter der koalition zu
erklären warum sie haben doch in vielen
reden hier und in der öffentlichkeit zu
recht gesagt wir müssen jetzt alles tun
um wegzukommen von russischem gas wir
müssen alles tun und das durch heimische
produktion zu ersetzen da haben wir eine
möglichkeit und die ausgerechnet soll es
in ihrem entwurf gedeckelt werden das
werden wir nicht methan
sie wollen einen deckel auch ein ziel
für modernisierungen bei der wasserkraft
wir sind der meinung dass auch die
wasserkraft mit ihren möglichkeiten
einen beitrag leisten muss das falsch
ist sie nachrangig zu behandeln dass es
falsch ist mit ihren vorschlägen zur
vergütung modernisierung zu verhindern
weil modernisierung nicht nur zu mehr
erneuerbaren energien sondern auch zu
besseren bedingungen bei der
gewässerökologie führen sie machen ein
deckel in ihren vorschlägen bei der
wasserkraft die wasserkraft ist es faule
erster paket das muss sich ändern und so
werden wir uns in den beratungen
einbringen
wir unterstützen ausdrücklich alle
vorschläge die dazu geeignet sind die
gerade wärmeproduktion durch geothermie
voranzubringen dabei auch akzeptanz zu
schaffen die
rahmenbedingungen zu verbessern da ist
jetzt im gesetz wer weiß schon länger
enthalten die ankündung es gibt
irgendwann eine degression ohne zu sagen
wann die kommen könnte da sind wir der
meinung da sollten wir es gemeinsam eine
initiative machen das konkretisieren
weil die unsicherheit wann könnte ist
unter welchen bedingungen eine
degression geben das widerspricht der
planungssicherheit deshalb müssen wir
auch da besser verankern
ausdrücklich unterstützen wir die
bemühungen die sonnenenergie zu nutzen
auf dächern auf parkplätzen auf
vielen flächen auch gewerbeflächen
konnte sie uns flächen auch in der
doppelnutzung und nutzungskonflikte zu
vermeiden wir glauben aber dass das was
im erneuerbaren energien gesetz gemacht
wird ergänzt werden natürlich eine ganz
klare botschaft nämlich steuerfreiheit
für die kleinen pv anlagen bis zu einer
installierten leistung von 30 kw der mit
der letzten periode ein anfang gemacht
bis 10 kw es gibt eine
bundesratsinitiative des landes baden
württemberg vorgestellt von den grünen
finanzminister die unterstützen wir das
wir ein ganz klare botschaft wer sich so
eine anlage auf das dach macht derzeit
keine steuern das ist eine ermunterung
für den ausbau an bei allergien ist ein
abbau von bürokratie ihren wird ein
schub automatisch bringen das werden wir
in die beratungen einbringen
und den ausbau der windenergie die
beschleunigt werden muss auch dieses
ziel teilen wir wo sich vorstellen
immerhin zum ausgleich von erneuerbaren
energien und atemschutz andere
vorschläge im planungsverfahren die
richtig sind möchten wir darauf dringen
dass der gedanke der regionalplanung
verstärkt wird die regionalplanung ist
die möglichkeit ziele verbindlich
festzulegen und dann tatsächlich auf im
planungsverfahren eben in dialog im aus
leicht zu erreichen aber gleichzeitig
akzeptanz zu schaffen mit anderen
anliegen das ist uns ein besonders
wichtiges anliegen und das kann nur
erreicht werden mit einem engen mit
einer engen abstimmung mit den
bundesländern wir brauchen ein breites
gesellschaftliches bild ist das beginnt
aber damit dass ihre reise durch die
bundesländer ist echte verhandlungen
folgen in denen man sich auf ziele auf
instrumente auf ein gemeinsames vorgehen
verständigt da haben wir die erwartung
dass das jetzt der nächste schritt ist
das haben wir bisher nicht wahrgenommen
dass aber notwendig um die
fortschrittlichen notwendig sind mit
breiter akzeptanz voranzubringen
herzlichen dank
andreas der
klimaschutz und energiepolitische
sprecher der unions-fraktion konnten sie
auch im viertel vor neun schon bei uns
im interview sehen und wie ist die
fügung und der zufall will die nächste
rednerin auch schon heute morgen bei uns
im interview gewesen nina scheer aus der
spd fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
bereits vor dem russischen angriffskrieg
und den sich angeschlossenen maßnahmen
zur beendigung der import abhängigkeiten
von energie aus russland war der
schnellstmöglichen umstieg auf
erneuerbare energie die zwingende und
schlüssige konsequenz zur begrenzung des
menschgemachten klimawandels nun muss
aber eben jetzt erst recht vor dem
hintergrund des angriffskrieges gelten
diese politik beschleunigt zu verfolgen
auch um nicht erpressbar zu werden die
uns ministerrat habe gerade schon
erläuterte kündigte russland gestern
un-sanktionen gegen teile des
gaskonzerns gazprom germania an der seit
anfang april unter der
treuhandverwaltung der bundesnetzagentur
steht und es ist noch offen welchen
einfluss dies auf die weiteren importe
haben wird auch werden aktuell die
gasversorgung gesichert ist genau zu
beobachten ist aber an dieser stelle
auch
werden von seiten der ukraine zur zeit
ein durchleitung stalkern gas aus
russland verfolgt wird es muss auch hier
ausgeschlossen werden können dass diese
maßnahmen nicht ein gegen deutschland
gerichtetes druckmittel sind auch dies
wäre inakzeptabel
wirtschaft und gesellschaft sind auch
ein fossiler ressourcen bei gleichzeitig
steigender weltbevölkerung und noch
dringlicher die klimafolgen wirkungen
aus verbrennung fossiler
energieressourcen erfordern verstärktes
hatte wir brauchen den
schnellstmöglichen umstieg auf
erneuerbare energien über brauchen wir
brauchen die beseitigung von
mengenbegrenzungen die sich über die
letzten jahre angehäuft haben und wir
brauchen die beseitigung von vielen
versteckten
planungssystem nissen
in diesem handel steckt die chance auf
energiesicherheit es steckt die chance
auf überwindung von konflikten und
kriegen um fossile ressourcen die wir
schon hatten etwa in den irak kriege und
auch auf vermeidung von massiven
gesundheitsschäden die durch die
verbrennung fossiler ressourcen sowie
weitere klima und umwelt folgewirkungen
entstehen und in diesem handeln steckt
auch die vermeidung von biodiversitäts
verlusten durch klimawandel der beste
garant arten zu erhalten ist den
klimawandel zu stoppen
wenn wir also mit den oster paket das
wir nun parlamentarisch behandeln für 20
20 30 von 750 terawattstunden bedarf an
strom ausgehen ist dass deutlich mehr
als die heute benötigten 500 60
terawattstunden und wenn wir dann davon
80 prozent also von diesen 750
terawattstunden 80 prozent strom aus
erneuerbaren energien haben wollen so
steht es in unserem koalitionsvertrag
dann ist das so viel wie wir heute an
energie 100 prozent dann hätten wir das
ist uns das was wir vorhaben in acht
jahren wollen wir 80 prozent erreichen
das ist die menge die ihm auch heute
bezogen eine 100 prozent versorgung
durch erneuerbare energien bedeutet das
ist ein großer kraftakt das ist aber
auch notwendig um genau diese
schwierigkeiten die ich gerade erläutert
happ zu überwinden und es muss uns klar
sein die erneuerbaren energien sind die
günstigsten form energie zu gewinnen die
kostengünstigsten form und je schneller
wir es schaffen auf diese umzusteigen
desto schneller machen wir uns
unabhängig von preissteigerungen und
justus so schneller machen wir uns
unabhängig von erpressbarkeit die
aktuell wegen import abhängigkeiten
bestehen
und auch da kurz anzuschließen die sonne
schickt uns keine
20-jährige oder 15-jährigen
vertragsbindung
mit oder mit französische versprochen
gesprochen sie schickt die sonne schickt
uns keine rechnung solange die nutzung
fossiler energie noch nicht gänzlich
überwunden wurde und aktuell an einem
umstieg auf alternative bezugsquellen
auch für fossile energien gearbeitet
wird darf es zu keiner schleichenden
faktischen bevorzugung von fossilen
energieträgern gegenüber erneuerbaren
energien geführt wenn wir heute etwa das
lg gesetzt auch mit einbringen auf das
meine kollegen timon gremmels und auch
genk merck noch eingehen werden wird es
auch darauf kommen ankommen dass hier
verbriefte öffentliche interesse das
überragende öffentliche interesse was
angesichts der notlage dort verbrieft
ist für den bau von lng an land
möglichkeiten
auch in übertragung auf erneuerbare
energien zu verbriefen es darf nicht
sein
es darf nicht sein dass wir zu einer
schleichenden ziel verschiebung kommt
durch diese prioritätensetzung die
angesichts des krieges auch uns
hereinprasselt und wir dann am ende von
solchen gesetzgebungsverfahren auf
einmal erkennen müssen wir haben eine
bevorzugung von fossilen energieträgern
gegenüber erneuerbaren nein es muss
umgekehrt seien die erneuerbaren
energien müssen immer das bevorzugte
sein sonst lernen wir uns in der
energiewende statt sie zu befördern und
natürlich
auch nochmal einzugehen natürlich darf
es auch keine deckelung keine neuen
deckelungen im kontext der europäischen
rahmen schätzung die wir haben geben
sondern die erneuerbaren energien sind
ohne deckel voran zu bringen das ist das
primat der erneuerbaren energie er
stellt sich zudem die aufgabe
engpässe zu überwinden wir haben massive
lieferketten schwierigkeiten die
betreffen natürlich auch die
energiewende auch hier müssen wir
schnellstens handelt es darf nicht sein
dass diese auswirkungen sich auch in der
energiewende niederschlagen wir haben
enorme weichenstellungen vor mit dem
oster paket die planungs vermisse die
genehmigungs hemmnisse zu überwinden
eine reihe von maßnahmen sind dort
enthalten weitere folgen noch durch
weitere vorlagen die auch das sind
vielleicht ein beschleunigungsgesetz was
uns in den nächsten wochen noch
erreichen wird ich freue mich auf die
konstruktive zusammenarbeit in der
ampelkoalition die wirklich vieles
vorhat und vieles auch schon angeschoben
hat und jeder ist eingeladen dies
konstruktiv zu begleiten vielen dank
nina scheer ist in der spd
fraktionssprecherin für klimaschutz und
energie und verkehr den standpunkt ihrer
fraktion noch einmal dargelegt in einer
debatte in dem es um in denen es über
drei gesetzentwürfe der bundesregierung
geht zum ausbau erneuerbarer energien
und dazu jetzt aus der afg fraktion
steffen kothe der energiepolitische
sprecher
sehr geehrte damen und herren herr
minister habeck wenn die russen jetzt
gegen sanktionen machen dann ist das
doch nur eine reaktion auf
dem umstand dass sie doch angefangen
haben energie als waffe einzusetzen sie
haben doch von
am barren gesprochen was sie umsetzen
wollen und viele viele andere dinge auch
also wenn jetzt der bumerang zurück
kommt dann muss man sich eigentlich
nicht wundern und der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien das ist eben kein
abschied von fossilen das ist einfach
nur ein abschied von der vernunft meine
damen und herren weil wir ohne fossile
gar nicht auskommen
und natürlich haben sie richtigerweise
angesprochen dass wir in eine welt jetzt
immer mehr probleme haben eben mit der
versorgung mit lebensmitteln
aber eben auch sehen wir dass wir
energie armut haben und wir tragen auch
dazu bei indem wir unsere
energieversorgung schreddern und hier
wolkenkuckucksheim machen wollen mit
diesen sogenannten erneuerbaren
funktioniert nicht wir sehen dass die
energieversorgung nachlässt und abgebaut
wird und dann ist natürlich ganz klar
dass wir dann keine energie mehr
woanders auch zur verfügung haben und
die so genannte bürger energie die ich
immer höre wo sich also bürger jetzt
selber um die stromerzeugung kümmern
sollen ja das ist doch irgendwie ein
zeichen dass wir wieder wie zu
mittelalterlichen zuständen zu bekommen
nein wir haben eine arbeitsteilung in
unserer volkswirtschaft diese
arbeitsteilung war es in unternehmen
dafür zuständig dass sie den strom
erzeugen und frau dr
die erneuerbaren energien sind nicht
billiger es fossilen sondern teurer
bestes beispiel streichen doch das
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz ist dann
streichen wir damit auf die subvention
und sie werden sehen dass die
erneuerbaren energien nicht mehr
ausgebaut werden können weil sie völlig
und ökonomische sind also es ist ein
bestes beispiel
und die fossilen werden nicht bevorzugt
nein im gegenteil sie werden behindert
ihn genau durch das erneuerbare energien
gesetzt weil sie nämlich immer dann
zurücktreten müssen wenn die
erneuerbaren
instabilen ins netz eingespeist werden
müssen also das völliger coco logos zu
sagen dass fossile hier bevorzugt werden
und man kann im übertragenen sinne auch
sagen dass der ausbau der windenergie
ein ausbau von parasitärer energie ist
denn diese wetter in einer abhängigen
wind industrieanlagen die brauchen dem
ich diese frau sheila stromversorgung
nicht immer dann wenn sie wenn sie
aussetzen und kein strom erzeugen und
dann springen nämlich die fossilen ein
so ist das nämlich und nicht anders und
das erneuerbare energien gesetz erhält
die erneuerbaren instabilen energien
einfach nur künstlich am leben meine
damen und herren
und wenn wir uns die wild
industrieanlagen anschauen dann sehen
wir das also umweltverschmutzer sind
beton stahl öl und kahlschlag in unserer
landschaft lärm in feld und flur und
nunmehr lesen wir das also diese
industrieanlagen sogar leider in
schutzgebieten naturschutzgebiete
aufgestellt werden dürfen und das ist
ein unding das ist völliger unsinn und
es gab mal eine umweltschutz partei und
die ist aber leider längst beerdigt gab
auch mal eine friedenspartei ist auch
beerdigt im gegenteil ist leider der
fall und wenn wir uns also diese
windindustrie anlagen noch mal genau
anschauen dann gibt es ja die neuesten
studien auch die sagen sie führen zu
mehr wärme und trockenheit in mikroklima
bereich neueste studien sagen das und
das ist ja genau das gegenteil von dem
was sie vorgeben eigentlich mit diesem
windindustrie anlagen auswirken zu
wollen und insofern ist das wieder ein
neuer aspekt in dieser gesamten
irrationalen energiepolitik in dieser
gesamten welt dümmsten energiepolitik
meine damen und herren
ja und woran erkennen wir diktaturen wie
erkennen sie an der einschränkung der
rechte und woran erkennen wir die
anfänge einer links grün gelben
ökodiktatur eben genau an der
einschränkung der
einspruchsmöglichkeiten für die bürger
und wenn ich dann höre dass schon wieder
diskutiert wird dass man die
abstandsregeln zu wohnhäusern jetzt
schleifen will das also jeder in seinen
vorgarten so eine windindustrie anna
hingestellt bekommen kann und dann auch
noch der prozess weg eingeschränkt ist
meine damen und herren weil dann hat das
nichts mehr mit einem rechtsstaat zu tun
so wie wir ihn verstehen meine damen und
herren und so wie wir ihn von der afg
auch verteidigen
und windindustrie anlagen jetzt noch als
nationales als gegenstand der nationalen
sicherheit zu deklarieren also erstmal
völlig erholen im gegenteil diese
windindustrie anlagen sind nationales
sicherheitsrisiko für mensch wird hier
für umwelt und für die versorgung
darunter machen wir lieber in
kernenergie da kommen wir besser voran
dankeschön
städten q3 der energiepolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion mit der raf
die perspektiven auf dieses thema das
hier heute vormittag im bundestag
verhandelt und diskutiert wird es folgte
michael grusa muss der fdp fraktion aber
er ist energiepolitischer sprecher
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrter herr kodré sie sprechen von den
anfängen einer diktatur ich stelle mal
fest in diesem land besteht
meinungsfreiheit die tatsache dass sie
von diesem pult hier jeden schuss ab
sondern dürfen denen sie sich zu
überlegen das beste indiz dafür dass sie
diesen mann meinungsfreiheit ich
kann ja verstehen
ich kann ja verstehen dass sie sich
gerne weiterhin auf russland verlassen
möchten ein blick in die zahlungsströme
die es so in ihre richtung gibt legt
nahe sie können diesen abstand auch
finanziell nicht gut verkraften aber wir
alle wissen dass die großen koalition
die letzten beiden großen koalitionen
sich genau wie sie auf russland
verlassen haben und ich stelle fest
jetzt sind wir verlassen weil wir uns zu
lange auf russland verlassen haben und
deswegen und deswegen unternehmen wir
jetzt mit höchstgeschwindigkeit alle
maßnahmen die erforderlich sind um uns
unabhängig zu machen von russland
deswegen besprechen wir hier in heute
das lng infrastruktur
beschleunigungsgesetz deswegen gehen wir
mit fullspeed voran wenn es darum geht
jetzt alternativen zu schaffen zu dem
was sie gerne noch weiter etablieren
würden wir gehen diesen wirklich mit und
zum glück wird uns ein großer teil der
bevölkerung in deutschland meine lieben
kolleginnen
wir machen ja aktuell den größten ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien denen es in
den letzten 25 jahren wahrscheinlich
jemals gegeben hat und mit diesem großen
ausbaus auch eine große verantwortung
verbunden insbesondere auch für uns hier
im hause im verfahren denn es ist ja
nicht üblich dass wir in diesem
verfahren ein gesetzentwurf durch das
kabinett durchgeht und es an der einen
oder anderen stelle abgestimmter weise
noch diskussionsbedarf gibt ich bin dem
minister deswegen sehr dankbar dass er
hier in dem minister sehr dankbar dass
er hier an dieser stelle auch die
entsprechenden punkte entsprechend
eingeordnet hat denn die verantwortung
für den erfolg dieses gesetzes liegt
jetzt bei diesem haus und auch die
verantwortung für eine einigung über
wichtige ziele die wir mit diesem gesetz
erreichen wollen liegt bei diesem haus
und gerade in richtung derjenigen die
ihr hier jetzt immer dazwischen
schreiben sage ich auch sie liegt nicht
nur bei denjenigen die hier die
regierung tragen sondern einfluss auf
dieses verfahren hat jeder einzelne und
jede einzelne abgeordnete und wir haben
mit den beiden
gesetzgebungsverfahren die wir jetzt
bereits abgeschlossen haben im bereich
der gasspeicher und im bereich der
energiesicherheit gezeigt dass wir
konstrukt diese hinweise aus der
opposition sehr wohl bereit sind nicht
nur zur kenntnis zu nehmen sondern auch
in unsere gesetze einzuarbeiten
herr kollege das ist nicht großzügig
sondern das ist klug nein ich tun nicht
nur so sondern wir bauen gute
entscheidungen gute ideen auch aus der
opposition sind wir uns nicht zu fein
dafür dass aufzunehmen wissen sie was
das problem mit ihnen ist das problem
ist aus dieser richtung ist noch kein
einziger konstruktiver vorschlag
gekommen für unsere gesetze dass das
ganze problem
wir wollen mit wir wollen mit dem
erneuerbaren energien gesetz dafür
sorgen dass wir klimaneutrale
energieversorgung
erreichen wir möchten dass in
deutschland ein luxusgut zum standard
wird das ist das was wir hier machen wir
sorgen dafür dass die erneuerbaren
energien für jeden bezahlbar werden wir
sorgen auch dafür dass an den stellen wo
wir gesehen haben es gibt eine riesen
kostendegression wir haben die
erneuerbaren nämlich in allen bereichen
hingelegt sie habe das nicht zur
kenntnis genommen aber es hat trotzdem
der fall dass in den bereichen wo die
kostendegression so groß ist dass es
möglich ist auch ein einstieg in den
ausstieg der dauersubventionierung
erfolgt denn es ist nicht das ziel
entschuldigung gestatten wir eine
zwischenfrage aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
selbstverständlich verbinden
ich finde das spiel frage zugelassen
vielleicht hören sie zu sehen die
präsidentin mit mir spricht oder ich mit
dir
vielen dank dass sie die zwischenfrage
zugelassen haben sie haben gesagt sie
würden konstruktive vorschläge von uns
würdigen wir haben beim ensi gestern
erlebt dass sie unseren vorschlag
abgelehnt haben wo wir mehrfach vorher
auf das problem hingewiesen haben dass
für die treuhänder im bereich von
von den fossilen energien also natürlich
insbesondere gast deutschland und
das ist der ungelöste rechtsfragen gibt
wir haben dazu weshalb ein
änderungsantrag gemacht dann haben sie
abgelehnt das heißt auch ihr zwischen
wofür würden gar keine vorschläge machen
ist sowohl nicht zutreffen
warum haben sie denn eigentlich
abgelehnt ja kann ich ihnen gerne bad
sondern zunächst einmal alles was was
ich hier eben vom rednerpult gesagt habe
hat sich ausdrücklich in dieser sache
nicht an ihre fraktion gerichtet sondern
ich hatte ja vielmehr darauf hingewiesen
dass es aus ihrer fraktion auch
konstruktive hinweise zum entdecker
bisher die debatte zum endsieg heute
abend deswegen werde ich die nicht in
gänze vorziehen aber sie haben
sicherlich zur kenntnis genommen dass
wir kolleginnen und kollegen aus ihrer
fraktion intensiv in den
beratungsprozess zu diesem zu diesem
gesetz eingebunden haben auch wesentlich
intensiver als das üblich oder notwendig
ist und das hat er ja gründe die gründe
dafür waren dass wir dieses gesetz
wirklich großem tempo durch dieses haus
gebracht haben und wir haben eben als
regierungsfraktionen auch die
verantwortung verstanden dass wir auch
oppositionsfraktionen auf dem weg
mitnehmen und auch konstruktive hinweise
aus diesem bereich auf mit sie finden
dass im bereich des m6 etwa wieder bei
der verordnung die es geben muss für den
fall dass wir schwer wiegende
eigentumsrechtliche eingriffe vornehmen
in diesem fall muss eine verordnung hier
auch durch den deutschen bundestag sich
sogar genehmigungspflichtig durch den
deutschen bundestag in drei
sitzungswochen muss das passieren dass
ein vorschlag der wie ich ihnen sagen
kann explizit in der ersten lesung in
diesem hause
ihrem kollegen jungen hier geäußert
wurde ist etwas was wir aufgegriffen
haben weil es ein sehr kluger ratschlag
war und wie sie hören wenn ich mir auch
gar nicht zu fein dafür diese klugen
ratschläge von dieser stelle hier auch
aus zu lobt das heißt allerdings nicht
dass jeder vorschlag der aus einer
oppositionsfraktion kommt am ende auch
in jedem gesetz drin stehen wird ich
glaube dass allerdings werden sie mir
nachsehen können insofern ich habe jetzt
erläutert wann wir konstruktive
vorschläge und welche konstruktiven
vorschläge wie auch aufgenommen haben an
dieser stelle ist es bei diesem einen
geblieben und dann alles weitere dazu
vielleicht in der debatte heute abend
herr kollege
gut zurück zum
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz worüber wir
hier eigentlich gerade debattieren wir
haben schon im koalitionsvertrag
wichtige weichenstellungen vorgenommen
die zielstellung wir haben das
öffentliche interesse der erneuerbaren
energien deutlich hervorgehoben und wir
sind auch auf einem wichtigen weg uns
alle anderen bereiche die hier in der
öffentlichkeit und in der
fachöffentlichkeit kritisch diskutiert
werden noch einmal anzuschauen die
kleine wasserkraft ist angesprochen
worden und ich kann für unsere fraktion
sagen dass es uns auch sehr wichtig ist
darauf zu schauen dass das geld was wir
hier für den erneuerbaren ausbau
einsetzen auch wirklich die volle
wirkung entfalte dass wir also sehr
darauf gucken werden welchen grenznutzen
der eingesetzt euro betrifft das wir
ihnen gerade da einsetzen wo er den
maximalen nutzen erzielt damit wir mit
dem ausbau der erneuerbaren rest
wirklich und schnellst möglich
vorankommen herzlichen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
michael kruse aus der fdp-fraktion hat
zwischendrin noch eine zwischenfrage von
thomas heilmann beantwortet und jetzt
geht's in der debatte weiter klaus ernst
ist ja nicht so redner aus der fraktion
die linke in der letzten
legislaturperiode also in der vorherigen
war er wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher
der beschleunigte ausbau erneuerbarer
energien
ist nicht nur ein gebot der stunde das
waren eigentlich schon vorher das soll
unterstützen wir natürlich folge
richtungen die es jetzt geht
mich freut auch dass die union jetzt
auch voll mit macht der junge es war
nicht immer so im letzten jahr habe ich
den eindruck habe sie standen ein
bisschen auf der bremse das hat auch ihr
koalitionspartner damals auch oft
bemängelt wenn wir jetzt
wenn wir jetzt eine neue dynamik haben
dann ist es gut und richtig
das ziel ist ambitioniert
windenergie
8,5 jahre verdoppeln
photovoltaik-anlagen dreieinhalb mal so
viel windenergie auf see über vier bin
ich richtig verstanden habe
ich glaube wir müssen auch darüber reden
was alles passiert das wird es
vielleicht nicht erreichen könnten und
dann über die schranken reden die
versuchen die die wir versuchen müssen
zu lösen dass wir dieses ziel auch
erreichen wenn wir jetzt steht nur noch
auf dem papier
bis jetzt ist noch nicht passiert das
heißt bis jetzt haben wir noch genau
dieselben abhängigkeiten wie vorher die
wir ändern wollen und ich sage ihnen
eins nach dem entgegen steht was sie
vorher um das ist die frage
wie entwickeln sich eigentlich die
preise weil alles was sie vorschlagen
erfordern ein höchstmaß an investitionen
auch der privaten und wenn ich dann den
privaten zu hören wir hatten letzten
montag eine anhörung bei uns im
ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
dann sagt zum beispiel die glasindustrie
als allein durch die preissteigerungen
bei energie die wir zurzeit haben ein
sinnvoller betrieb von von glashütten in
der bundesrepublik kaum noch möglich ist
wir hatten da eine derartige überlegt
sogar seine künftigen investitionen in
den usa zu machen liegt man bei uns wir
haben gleichzeitig hohe
preissteigerungen bei denen die wir
brauchen für investitionen dass sie das
was man mit neuen energien erreichen
wollen auch umsetzen und das sage ich
damit ist nur schon darüber nachdenken
ob das was wir momentan da machen auch
hinsichtlich der sanktionen wirklich
zielführend ist wenn wir sagen wenn wir
sagen wir sind ja das sagen bis jetzt
liefern die russen an grund jedenfalls
zuverlässig bis jetzt aber wenn wir
natürlich denken dauernd sagen wir
nämlich und mit euch euren kram nicht
mehr ab dann ist natürlich auch
irgendwann zu überlegen was machen
eigentlich die anderen also beim schach
habe ich gelernt wenn ich an zu machen
muss ich überlegen bevor ich denn machen
was macht der andere was kommt ja die
konnte reagieren und selbstverständlich
hätten wir ein riesenproblem das liest
man jetzt wenn das eintritt was sie am
anfang ihrer linie dargestellt haben
werden tatsächlich aufgrund dessen wir
müssen jetzt reagieren wie den
energieversorgungs stopp mit gas hätten
also wäre es doch jetzt auch ihre
aufgabe euch bundesregierung zu gucken
wie könne man dies verhindern
nicht nur bekümmern das weit mit weiter
unsererseits mit sanktionen drohen
sondern über nicht verhindern weil ich
habe den eindruck wenn man so
weitermachen gefährden hiermit unsere
politik auf dieser seite die
energiepolitik die wir wollen auf der
anderen seite und dann haben mit
zitronen gehandelt aber nichts erreicht
haben
[Applaus]
ist es nicht so wichtig da ist es nur
richtig dreht sich die klagen immer die
raffinerie in schwedt ich war dort sie
waren auch befeuert wird
wenn ich mit den leuten gesprochen habe
ich ja es war heute nicht verhindern
wenn ich mit den leuten sprechen sagen
sie ja wir haben ein riesenproblem weil
die logistik für alternativen dass wir
dieses ist also diese ölversorgung
weiter befreit überhaupt noch nicht
gegeben ist wenn ich danach rechne die
vorschläge die es gibt dann komme ich zu
dem ergebnis das ist kein ist nicht so
ist dass die raffinerie in irgendeiner
weise gesichert ist also ich bitte sie
einfach darüber nachzudenken dass wenn
man die ziele die sich hier vortragen
und die sind ja gut und richtig die
unterstützen wir auch gerne aber da
müsste doch alles tun dass es auch
klappt umklappen tut ist nicht mehr
durch die maßnahmen im sonst eher
greifen zu einem preisentwicklung
beitragen die nur die bürger in einer
unerträglichen weise belastet sondern
auch die unternehmen weil sie
investitionen die sie für neue energien
brauchen nicht haben und deshalb
überlegen sie bitte ob das alles richtig
ist was ich so was sie tun sonst sind
ihre ambitionierten ziele die wir
nachdrücklich unterstützen eigentlich
für die johnny herzlich
klaus ernst aus der linksfraktion
vorsitzender im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie es folgt julia
fehlenden aus der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen stellvertretende
vorsitzende dort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren man kurz auf das
angesprochene energiegesetz einzugehen
dass wir jetzt im parlament beraten
werden dabei ist natürlich wichtig dass
wir uns mit den europäischen partnern
abstimmen auch deren geplanten
kapazitäten im blick haben dazu gehört
natürlich dass wir sorgfältig bei den
aufzubauenden kapazitäten eine gute
balance achten zwischen
selbstverständlich notwendiger notfall
absicherung für den fall der fälle in
den nächsten jahren und
selbstverständlich auch eine
wirtschaftlichkeit dieser kapazitäten
und selbstverständlich gehört dazu dass
es bei der laufzeit für fossile
flüssiggas nutzung auch auf die
klimaziele abgestimmt wird und last not
least dass es eine in dieser
krisensituation angemessene beteiligung
für öffentliche belange gibt
denn klar ist doch klar ist doch dass
der erdgasverbrauch bei uns in europa in
den nächsten jahren deutlich sinken wird
und zugleich muss die dringend
notwendige infrastruktur auch für
wasserstoff aufgebaut werden ich denke
wir werden sehr verantwortungsvoll und
zügig diesen gesetzentwurf beraten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen eine
fundamentale transformation unserer
gesellschaft steht an wir handeln gegen
die stetig steigenden temperaturen und
um die eskalierende klimakrise
abzubremsen vorgestern teilte die
weltwetterorganisation mit dass ein
überschreiten der 1 5 grad grenze schon
bis 20 26 möglich sein in deutschland
haben wir im jahresdurchschnitt die 2
grad erhitzt und schon fast erreicht und
hier in berlin und brandenburg geht es
jetzt in das fünfte jahr der dürre
das gesetzespaket ist ein wichtiger
schritt gegen das fieber des planeten
und zugleich eine krisenreaktion gegen
teurere energiepreise gegen fossile
inflation und gegen fossil
abhängigkeiten
und was wir heute im parlament
einbringen das hätte schon vor jahren
passieren müssen wir stellen als erstes
den zielkorridor neu auf mit ausbau
fahren bei windenergie und solar energie
die uns auf den weg zu einem
dekarbonisierung stromsektor bringt es
liegen noch einige wochen debatten vor
uns bis wir uns hier zum beschluss
dieser gesetzesnovellen wiedersehen aber
schon jetzt ist sicher wir werden uns
für die besten bedingungen für den
ausbau der erneuerbaren einsetzen die in
den letzten 20 jahren hatte
damit ist das startsignal das
startsignal für den turbo ausbau jetzt
da im eeg stellen wir nur noch fest was
in diesen tagen so offensichtlich ist
wie nie die erneuerbaren energien sind
im öffentlichen interesse das stand
übrigens bereits auch mal in dem entwurf
der eeg-novelle in der letzten
legislatur aber dass die von der union
haben das dann schnell lieber wieder
gestrichen ist also ein schönes beispiel
für ihre energiepolitische
kurzsichtigkeit mein appell an sie alle
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen machen
sie im wahlkreis werbung für die
erneuerbaren energien setzen sie sich
ein setzen sie sich ein für die
freiheits energien vor ort denn die
dezentrale die erneuerbare
energieversorgung luft vor ort gemacht
das gilt für das mit pouring von alten
windrädern genauso wie für die flächen
bereitstellung der neuen solarparks wir
schaffen hier im parlament die
grundlagen aber gebaut wird vor ort also
rauf mit der photovoltaik auf die dächer
auch auf turnhallen und auf rathäuser
liebe kommunen stellen sie denn jetzt
dringend die benötigten flächen zur
verfügung ermöglichen sie die dringenden
notwendigen investitionen alle müssen
mithelfen damit wir schneller sind die
klimakrise
mit dem neuen eeg wird es außerdem auch
endlich wieder raum für die bürger
energie geben die energiewende hat eine
große unterstützung in der bevölkerung
und bürger energie ermöglicht dass alle
unbürokratisch selbst bei dieser trend
transformation mitmachen können zum
beispiel ohne ausschreibung loslegen
können plus die bundesregierung hat
bereits eckpunkte für ein separates
förderprogramm der bürgerenergie nach
dem vorbild von schleswig-holstein
vorgelegt ich bin dafür sehr dankbar
liebe freunde und wir gehen und kollegen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen packen
wir es an ich freue mich auf die
beratungen
die julia verbänden aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen hat das lng gesetz
angesprochen lng also liquefied natural
gas also verflüssigtes erdgas das ist
der vierte gesetzentwurf der hier heute
morgen und mit beraten gilt nämlich die
infrastruktur für dieses verflüssigte
erdgas auszubauen in deutschland um gas
engpässe zu verhindern thomas heilmann
ist der nächste redner aus der
unionsfraktion meine lieben kolleginnen
und kollegen liebe oster paket gläubigen
wir unterstützen grundsätzlich die
intention ihres oster paketes den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien in deutschland
drastisch zu beschleunigen und
ausdrücklich wir begrüßen und
unterstützen auch die von ihnen auch
heute morgen wieder genannte begründung
warum gelassen
wir glauben allerdings nicht
dass sie ihre ziele und den
versprochenen erfolg mit diesen
maßnahmen allein werden erreichen können
auch die folge initiativen die sich ja
schon angekündigt haben und die
natürlich grundsätzlich auch den
richtigen zieren folgen werden diese
ziele nicht erreichen russland ist zwar
das fest der gläubigen aber wir sind
noch keine poster paket jünger und ich
sage ausdrücklich leider vielleicht
kriegen wir es ja noch irgendwie auch
die ampel redner gesagt haben warum
werden sie ihre ziele nicht erreichen
erstens sie setzten zu wenig auf den
markt und stattdessen auf kleinteilige
vorgaben der staat kann nicht alles
planen sondern er sollte den rahmen und
die richtung vorgeben und innerhalb
dessen den markt die beste lösung finden
lassen ich will ihnen ein beispiel geben
sie geben ziemlich genau vor welches
geschäftsmodell sie unterstützen
entweder man speist ein vollständig oder
man verbraucht den strom selbst
kombination mit netz dienlichen
speichern stellen sie schlechter sie
wollen keine biomasse andré aktion hat
es erwähnt selbst dann nicht wenn sie
aus stroh ästen oder anderen abfällen
stand wasserkraft leben sie praktisch
auch ab und nein frau verbinden auch die
bürgerenergie gesellschaften sind nicht
wirklich zufrieden und ich werde ihnen
gleich ein zitat von denen vorlesen ich
will doch sagen dass die informations
ausschreibungen zwar als instrument
jetzt fortsetzen aber in zu geringem
umfang diese gängelung sind grundfalsch
oder anders gesagt gerade an die adresse
der fdp freiheits energien brauchen
freiheit
zweite grundproblem dass wir sehen ist
sie wollen nur den bau von windrädern
und photovoltaik dächern beschleunigen
was richtig ist aber genauso entscheiden
im ganzen system sind übertragungsnetze
sind die speicher sind die transistoren
sind die neuen digitalen steuerung die
geothermie elektrisieren alle neuen
elemente für unsere neue wirtschaft
müssen beschleunigt werden nicht nur
bestimmte teile
denn die gesamte sich transformieren der
wirtschaft leidet unter langsamkeit
unnötigen vorschriften vielfach
dokumentationen widersprüchlichen
bescheiden und viel mehr wir müssen die
komplexität in unserem staat insgesamt
arbeiten spezial gesetzliche änderungen
sind richtig und wichtig aber wenn das
grundproblem unserer blockierten
verwaltung nicht angegangen wird dann
wird deutschland zu langsam zu
bürokratisch und zu starb laden das
sagen wir haben es nicht erst jetzt
sondern das sagen wir seit mehreren
jahren und sind ein bisschen enttäuscht
dass die neue ampel regierung auch bei
ihrer digitalstrategie die wirklich
entscheidenden schritte offen sie sich
nicht gehen möchte jetzt werden sie
gleich sagen das ist dass kritik der
sich die krise kritik sei dass bürger in
der opposition bitte lesen sie einmal
die vielen stellungnahmen zu ihren oster
paket wie ein roter faden zieht sich
unsere kritik durch die analysen der
fachleute und betroffene wie es auch oft
vorgetragen von institutionen die sich
seit jahren für klimaneutrale
wirtschaftsstarken hat der bundesverband
windenergie sagte sagt in ihrer
aktuellen version tragen die vorschläge
keinesfalls ausreichend zu einer lösung
der bestehenden blockaden bei von einem
bürokratie karussell über alle föderalen
ebenen stöhnt der schwertransporter
zuständige chef peter krafft
verkehrsbund das bündnis für bürger
energien frau verhindern wird mit dem
problem ein ganzes kapitel zum austrag
paketen oder der schönen überschrift
bürokratische hürden bleiben lösungen
werden vertragt das gesetz dürfe nicht
so wörtlich als schönheitsreparatur in
die geschichte eingehen gebraucht würde
die längst überfällige administrative
entschlackung des weges der förderverein
solarenergie schreibt in seiner analyse
der versprochene bürokratieabbau ist nur
in wenigen punkten umgesetzt wurden ja
in anderen feldern wurde der
bürokratieaufwand sogar noch erhöht das
handelsblatt resümiert warum hab ich's
oster paket auf der straße stecken
bleibt und am schluss noch am
zurückhaltend formulierte npd aber am
ende doch sehr klar wichtig für den
rasten zubau von erneuerbaren energien
ist eine entschlackung starke
beschleunigung der genehmigungsprozesse
von einer zügigen neuregelung dieser
frage wird der erfolg der energiewende
entscheidend abhängen dem kann man nur
zustimmen meine damen und herren
bundesminister habe ich sie haben
natürlich recht wir stehen gemeinsam vor
einer enormen herausforderung und da
stehen wir natürlich auch an ihrer seite
wir müssen die fortschreitende
dramatische erderwärmung stoppen und
dafür ist der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien natürlich richtig
und so haben wir keine wahl das jetzt
gemeinsam als nation anzugehen und auch
im parlament haben wir natürlich keine
andere wahl als zu versuchen das oster
paket für besser zu machen die es geht
ganz nach der struktur regel kein gesetz
geht aus dem bundestag sowie im haus wie
es hier hinein gekommen ist
ich freue mich dass sie dann sich auch
mit unseren verbesserungsvorschlägen
auseinandersetzen wie in den umfassende
mitwirkung an kritisch aber konstruktiv
wir stehen natürlich längst im austausch
mit den betroffenen unternehmen aber
auch sie meine damen und herren die sie
im saal hier sind oder an den digitalen
endgeräten sie können sich an uns wenden
an die mitglieder unserer arbeitsgruppe
klima es gibt noch ein klima kreis der
fraktionen es gibt die klima union alles
anknüpfungspunkte bei der sie auch ihre
verbesserung einbringen können wir
christdemokraten wollen ein turbo für
die erneuerbaren ostern ist für christen
das feste hoffnung bleiben wir also auch
für das oster paket optimistisch vielen
dank
thomas heilmann nochmal zum oster paket
mund hat dann auch noch mal den begriff
ein bisschen der teaser beleuchtet
können wir gerne auch noch mal ein wenig
ergänzen bis pfingsten jetzt noch
osterzeit insofern auch sprachlich hier
alles passen und der nächste redner in
dieser debatte ist timon gremmels aus
der spd fraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren diese vor bewertung sei
mir gestattet ich finde es immer
spannend wenn die union das redepult
tritt und dann erzählt die koalition die
ampel würde ihre ziele ihre
selbstgesteckten ziele nicht erreichen
also wer hat den 16 jahre hier regiert
das sollte man ihnen sozusagen noch mal
auf dem wir haben keine 16 wäre es wird
die spd 16 jahre die kanzler gestellt
hat das kommt erst noch ja aber sie
haben mit frau merkel die kanzlerin
gestellt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren der heimat die zeit mir nicht
mehr jetzt wissen sie wie es damals
waren der großen koalition peter
altmaier hat zu beginn der wahlperiode
ein sogenanntes 100 tagen gesetz
eingebracht unmöglich stellt kleinste
reformen am eeg vorzunehmen und es war
ihre fraktion die das blockiert hat wir
waren bereit als sozusagen demokratie
aus ihrem hause kollege pfeiffer nüßlein
oku
blockiert es war mir so peinlich dass er
einmal das gesetz unbenannt hat in
energie same gesetz weil es über 300
tage gedauert hat bis wir kleinste
änderung vorgenommen haben und die ampel
macht es genau umgekehrt sie liegt einen
großen entwurf das oster paket heute
hier noch knapp 200 tagen auf den tisch
das ist der unterschied meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren zwischen der
großen koalition unter ampeln es ist die
größte reform im 21 jahr des bestehens
erneuerbaren energie gesetz dass wir
heute hier diskutieren und heute
einbringen wir legen damit den
nachhaltigen turbo zum ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien an meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und natürlich
haben die ampel parteien und fraktionen
einen ganz unterschiedlichen zugang zu
diesen themen die grünen kommen in
erster linie über die schiene
klimaschutz die fdp hat ihren weg mit
den zu den erneuerbaren energien über
den begriff der freiheit energie
gewonnen die spd steht den erneuerbaren
energien im sinne einer demokratisierung
der energieerzeugung an erster stelle
für uns ist es wichtig die menschen
mitzunehmen ein mitmach projekt daraus
zu machen die bürger energien
voranzubringen weil das akzeptanz
steigert die kommunen mitzunehmen neue
einnahmequellen zu generieren die
stadtwerke mitzunehmen um auch
unabhängiger werden dort zu werden von
gas mieterinnen und mieter mitzunehmen
also auch menschen mit kleinerem
geldbeutel die vom preiswerten
sonnenstrom auf dem dach ihres
mietshauses profitieren das ist der
sozialdemokratische ansatz einer
energiepolitik beide sehr verehrten
damen und herren und neben der
demokratie sie auch ist der
sozialdemokratie der
wirtschaftspolitische aspekt wichtig
weil energiewende ist klassische
wirtschaftspolitik wir schaffen hier
zukunftsfähige gute arbeitsplätze meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren die
voraussetzungen dafür schaffen wir weil
das handwerk gestärkt wird weil wir
immer mehr unternehmen auch aus der
solar branche wieder zurückkommt und
module auch in deutschland produzieren
wechselrichter in deutschland
produzieren und wir müssen dazu zu sehen
gemeinsam herbeck dass wir auch die
windenergieindustrie hier in deutschland
behalten sie nicht abwandern lassen wir
brauchen gute standorte auch zur
fertigung von rotoren und schon
getrieben der windkraftanlage das ist
ganz wichtig zu bienen und ähnliches ja
und die ziele die wir uns koalition
gesetzt haben sind immens ich nehme nur
das beispiel der photovoltaik von wir
haben hier eine vervierfachung des
zubaus 22 gigawatt pro jahr wollen wir
schaffen und da geht es nicht dass wir
freiflächen gegen dachanlagen
gegeneinander auszuspielen wir brauchen
beides um es zu gelingen natürlich als
erstes die dächer voll machen aber wir
müssen auch gucken dass wir sinnvolle
freiflächen nutzen um diese ziele zu
erreichen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ja und wenn wir jetzt
gesetzgeberisch die weichen stellen
dafür dass der zubau gelingt müssen wir
industriepolitisch auch gucken dass wir
den fachkräftemangel dass wir den
lieferketten mangel beseitigen weil ich
auch aus meinem wahlkreis unternehmen
und kennedy würden gerade im bereich der
erneuerbaren energien deutlich mehr
verkaufen wenn dort der fachkräftemangel
beziehungsweise der lieferketten mangel
nicht gegeben wäre auch darum müssen wir
uns kümmern auch das muss moderne
industriepolitik meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und da wir heute nicht
nur über ihn reden sondern auch über das
lg beschleunigungsgesetz muss man
deutlich auch betonen hier werden
fossile energien beschleunigt das machen
wir nicht ganz freiwillig sondern weil
es eine notwendigkeit ist aber die
maßstäbe die wir hier anlegen beim
ausbau von energie ports die müssen
natürlich kann man nicht alles mit einem
vergleichen aber die müssen im grundsatz
nach auch für die erneuerbare berlin
gelten wir können nicht zulassen dass
wir hier sonderwege für die fossilen
energieträger geht die einen lock in
effekt verursachen meine damen und
herren
und da irgendwas wir tun ja wir haben
mit dem russischen angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine auch einen energieversorgungs
problem aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen
die klimakrise und die erderwärmung sind
nicht von der tagesordnung verschulden
wir müssen beide krisen und beide dort
legte zeitgleich lösen da bieten die
erneuerbaren energien eine gute
voraussetzung ich sage ihnen
abschließend zu für die spd fraktion
wir haben hier von herr beck und der
narr werk von minister hahn berg und der
bundesregierung einen guten
gesetzentwurf bekommen es ist unsere
aufgabe als koalitionsfraktionen wir
laden die opposition also die
demokratische opposition hat sich einen
guten gesetzentwurf noch besser zu
machen in diesem sinne alles gute glück
auf
timon gremmels für die spd fraktion in
der debatte zu gesetzentwürfen der
bundesregierung zum schnelleren ausbau
erneuerbarer energien und auch zu einer
neuen infrastruktur für lng terminals
beispielsweise also den für flüssiggas
ist wieder dran mit carsten hilse
heute um drei gesetzesentwürfe der
grünen kommunisten an das kann man die
ganze koalition nicht mehr nennen sie
alle wollen planwirtschaftlich die
stromerzeugung aus sogenannten
erneuerbaren in kürzester zeit drastisch
erhöhen als begründung wird die
alternativlosigkeit benannt und dass der
krieg in der ukraine die notwendigkeit
beschleunigte abkehr von fossilen
energieträgern einmal mehr aufgezeigt
hätte nicht nur dass sie das leid des
ukrainischen volkes durch den krieg hier
in unerträglicher weise
missbrauchen um eine völlig nutzlose nur
schaden verursachende sanktionspolitik
gegen russische brands schloss zu
rechtfertigen sie behaupten auch noch
wider besseren wissens und damit bewusst
lügen weil hundertfach widerlegt dass
andere länder unserem selbstmörderischen
vorbild folgen
anspricht der dakota sagt wenn du merkst
dass du ein totes pferd reitest steig ab
statt nun aber von jenen toten pferd
energiewende aussicht abzusteigen
versuchen die grünen kommunisten
herr gremlin ohne restalkohol geht's
besser
abzusteigen versuchen die grünen
kommunisten ist mit hilfe dieses
gewaltigen entschuldigung herr hill sich
bitte dass sie sich erstens
entschuldigen und zweitens auch diese
begriffe weder nazi noch kommunisten
benutzen wir hier im hause da würde ich
sie auch von betten also kommunist ist
es verboten
dass das können sie gerne zu protokoll
nehmen weil wir gesagt haben wir
benutzen solche begriffe hier im hause
nicht man muss sich nicht daran halten
habe ich will trotzdem auf hinweisen ich
bitte darum ich habe die redezeit
angehalten sie können jetzt weiter vor
frank alles klar
ich entschuldige mich bei herrn grimmels
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass sie unter
restalkohol stimmen
also
versuchen die grünen kommunisten es
mittels eines gewaltigen neuen
schuldenberges namens sondervermögens
energie und klimafonds wieder zum laufen
zu bringen da ist die rede von einer
ausbeute von
10.000 megawatt jährlich für die
windenergie im land um in 2030 die
fantasie mengen von 130.000 megawatt
installierter leistung zu erhalten das
wären ab sofort 2000 vogel killer der 5
megawatt klasse das sind die richtig
großen pro jahr dafür bräuchten wir pro
jahr fünf millionen tonnen beton und
stahl immerhin ein viertel der deutschen
jahresproduktion 430.000 tonnen
aluminium eine millionen tonnen kupfer
und zehntausende tonnen von rohstoffen
die wir importieren müssen und von
gleicher hirnrissige qualität das sind
die ausbauziele in der photovoltaik bloß
noch absurder das soll es von rund
65.000 megawatt installierter leistung
auf
215.000 megawatt gehen pro pro tag dazu
60 megawatt müssen dazu hinzugebaut
werden kommt gerechnet während das
600.000 quadratmeter fläche oder 80
fußballfelder jeden einzelnen tag die
stadt dresden plant sogar die
frauenkirche und die semperoper mit dem
chinesischen müll zu verunstalten und
wenn dann die sonne nicht scheint oder
der wind nicht weht ist vertrag trotzdem
0 sowie 130 tausend megawatt 000 sind
sind auch
354.000 megawatt mal 00 welch ein
irrsinn welcher eine anmaßung spricht
aus diesen
gesetzentwürfen in anbetracht von 4.300
maroden autobahnbrücken währende
regierung denkt sich diese hirnrissigen
zahlen aber es diese gesetze wurden von
ideologen und realitätsverweigerung
getrieben die schamlose krönung ist dass
in diesem gesetz steht für die bürger
gebe es keine erfüllung aufwand aus
natürlich den höchsten energiekosten der
welt dem massenhaften verlust wirtschaft
mehr arbeitsplätze und der fehlende und
weiter teile des deutschen volkes wäre
all das nicht will wendet sich von den
altparteien ab bei den zukünftigen
wahlen und wird die einzige alternative
schönen tag
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
konrad stockmeier
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin geschätzte
kolleginnen und kollegen der
koalitionsvertrag der ampel koalition
trägt er den titel mehr fortschritt
wagen und ich möchte an dieser stelle
betonen dass putins angriff auf die
ukraine weder titel noch inhalt des
koalitionsvertrages obsolet gemacht hat
sondern vielmehr unterstrichen hat worum
es auch gehen muss nämlich auch darum
mehr tempo zu wagen das gilt
insbesondere auch für den netzausbau
der mit dem ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien unbedingt einhergehen muss und
sowohl bezüglich der übertragungsnetze
als auch der verteilnetze beides packen
wir unter anderem mit der novellierung
des energiewirtschaftsgesetzes an und
ich dafür die freien demokraten an
dieser stelle freudig feststellen dass
es da auch viele elemente gibt die in
richtung digitalisierung gehen und somit
das ganze sowohl für stromproduzenten
netzbetreiber als auch für endkunden an
vielen stellen vereinfachen wird die
zeiten in denen netzbetreiber lastwagen
zu irgendwelchen behörden fahren in
denen dann unterlagen sind die müssen
ein ende finden
ein weiteres kernanliegen der freien
demokraten ist sehr wohl dass die kern
dass die energiewende auch so
kostengünstig und so marktgängig wie
möglich ins werk gesetzt werden muss und
ein entscheidender hebel um dies zu
realisieren
das möchte ich an dieser stelle betont
ist dass der netzausbau
bitte nicht nur deutsch sondern auch
europäisch gedacht und realisiert werden
muss in diesem sinne bin ich ihnen
minister habe ich sehr dankbar dafür
dass sie auch immer wieder betonen dass
es nicht um deutsche energieautarkie
gehen kann sondern dass wir das ganze
projekt auf europäisch denken müssen
denn wer wären wir denn wenn wir das
projekt der freiheits energien nur bei
uns und nur für uns denken würden es
muss doch auch darum gehen nicht nur
unsere freiheit sondern auch die unserer
partner in der europäischen union und
darüber hinaus zu sichern
welches panorama bietet sich da beim
netzausbau auf wenn man mit akteuren im
markt spricht das panorama des weit über
deutschland hinausgeht große offshore
wind kapazitäten beispielsweise in der
ostsee große photovoltaik kapazitäten in
süd europa und sagen wir es ruhig große
geschäftsmodelle und wenn wir an den
klima beauftragte der us-regierung john
kerry denken das ist jemand der kein
problem damit hat sowas auch ein big
business zu nennen und es stünde uns in
deutschland gut an wenn wir auch in
diese richtung denken und empfinden
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und
der netzausbau wird
somit die europäischen union ihre
partner und unser und unser aller
freiheit stärken und sichern und hat das
zeug die erneuerbaren energien
wohlgemerkt auch günstig zu machen und
auch wirklich das big business zu
realisieren und da möchte ich am zum
abschluss noch dazu sagen bei aller
freude die wir über den wahlsieg von
emanuel makro in frankreich empfunden
haben würde es uns jetzt auch gut zu
gesicht stehen seine europapolitischen
impulse nicht wieder versanden zu lassen
sondern sie konstruktiv aufzunehmen
warum bitteschön auch nicht im bereich
der energiepolitik da gibt es viele
chancen vielen dank
wie sagt konrad stockmeier aus der
fdp-fraktion und ihm wird jetzt folgen
in dieser debatte über den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien kathrin ohlig aus
der fraktion bündnis 90/die
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich komme aus
nordrhein westfalen dem energie und
industrieland in nrw wissen wir dass für
wirtschaft und industrie eine
verlässliche und bezahlbare
energieversorgung unerlässlich ist denn
nur so können wir arbeitsplätze
langfristig sichern und den
wirtschaftsstandort attraktiv gestalten
aktuell steigen die energiepreise weil
die fossilen energien noch teurer
geworden sind teurer denn teuer waren
sich für menschen und umwelt schon immer
dabei sind die folgekosten der
klimakrise noch nicht einmal
berücksichtigt wir brauchen jetzt einen
schnelleren ausbau der erneuerbaren für
das klima aber auch für die wirtschaft
denn wenn der wirtschaftsstandort
deutschland
zukunft wettbewerbsfähig soll sein soll
der minister hat es eben schon
angesprochen und wir arbeitsplätze
sichern wollen brauchen wir erneuerbaren
strom und grünen wasserstoff für
klimaneutrale produktionsverfahren
die wirtschaft steht bereits in den
startlöchern und mit diesem
gesetzespaket schaffen wir
planungssicherheit für investitionen und
einen verlässlichen rahmen für den
schnelleren ausbau der erneuerbaren
für deren umsetzung muss dieser wind der
veränderung von bayern bis
schleswig-holstein von nrw bis sachsen
wen deutschland hat die kompetenz das
know how die ideen mit sonne und wind
den wirtschaftsstandort der zukunft zu
gestalten und damit gleichzeitig einen
wichtigen schritt zur begrenzung der
klimakrise zu leisten lassen sie uns mit
diesem gesetzespaket die chance dafür
nutzen und herr heilmann das ist sicher
erst der anfang
herzlichen dank
kathrin ohlig für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen hier wird jetzt folgen
andreas lenz aus der unionsfraktion um
etwas präziser zu sein aus der
csu-landesgruppe
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
bestehen bei 50 prozent erneuerbare
energien im strombereich wir sind also
die letzten jahre massiv voran gekommen
beim ausbau der erneuerbaren aber wir
brauchen auch weiterhin einen massiven
ausbau um die ambitionierten ziele zu
erreichen und es ist nicht alles
schlecht was in diesem paket steht dem
sogenannten oster paket aber eben vieles
auch nicht richtig gut und insofern
beschränke ich mich jetzt erst mal auf
die dinge die defizitär sind die man
einfach auch besser machen könnte und um
es gleich zu beginn zu sagen wir
brauchen alle erneuerbaren wir müssen
die regionalen gegebenheiten optimal
nutzen und das wird in diesem oster
paket nicht gemacht ein ostergeschenk
ist es für viele eben nicht und so ist
es einfach nicht nachvollziehbar dass
die wasserkraft systematisch gegenüber
allen anderen erneuerbaren energien
benachteiligt wird
die wasserkraft soll als einzige
erneuerbare nicht im überragenden
öffentlichen interesse stehen julia
verbinden und da drängt sich doch die
frage auf da drängt sich doch die frage
des warum es auf man kann sich des
eindrucks einfach nicht erwehren dass
die geplanten lockerungen beim
artenschutz bei der windkraft durch
verschärfungen bei der wasserkraft quasi
eingetauscht wurden wasserkraft gehen
aber mit ökologischen gesichtspunkten
einher es wurde die letzten jahre viel
gemacht bei der durchlässigkeit auch
beim ausgleich zwischen ökonomie und
ökologie
wasserkraft ist grundlastfähig sie
stabilisiert das energiesystem insgesamt
das ist eine energieart die auch eine
insellösung darstellt gerade auch bei
problemen im energiesystem und ich
möchte an dieser stelle sagen wir stehen
zur wasserkraft und habe ich lade ich
sie gerne ein sich auch praxisbeispiele
entsprechend auch anzuschauen talents
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage oder
bemerkungen aus der fraktion bündnis 90
die grünen
lieber kollege lenz wir wissen ja dass
bayern sich sehr gerne an der
energiewende beteiligen würde was so
lang geht was wind angeht an dieser
entfesselung der erneuerbaren und
deswegen diskutiert die
csu-landtagsfraktion er schon lange
darüber wie können wir mehr flächen für
windenergie bereitstellen klar wir
wissen alle dass es eine einfache lösung
dafür gebe und daher würde ich ihnen
gern die gelegenheit geben heute hier im
plenum bei diesem top die abschaffung
der 10h windkraft abstandsregeln zu
verkünden
liebe frau warnungen dann für die
vergehen es gibt sich eben die
möglichkeit auch einiges dazu zu sagen
es ist zum einen so dass sie heute in
der bild -zeitung quasi in der bild
zeitung verkündet werden dass sie die
abschaffung sämtlicher abstände ja
sowieso schon vorhaben das müssen sie
dann natürlich auch den bürgerinnen und
bürgern entsprechende erklären das ist
das erste und das zweite das zweite ist
dass wir in bayern die bayerische
landtagsfraktion der csu jetzt ein
maßnahmenpaket geschnürt hat auch
übrigens nach rücksprache von minister
habeck und ministerpräsident söder dass
wir natürlich mehr flächen brauchen in
bayern und ich glaube das ist ein
praktikabler weg ist aber lassen sie
mich eines am ende noch sagen der ausbau
der windkraft geht nur mit den
bürgerinnen und bürgern und wir können
täglich über abstände diskutieren aber
es wird nicht funktionieren dass wir gar
keine abstände zu der wohnbebauung
letzten endes im gesetz auch fest
schreiben
aber sie haben sehr geschickt macht hier
haben ja eigentlich vom thema der
wasserkraft jetzt abgelenkt und das sagt
übrigens das sagen nicht wir sagen nicht
wir dass das worst case szenario dass
also der schlimmste fall für die kleine
wasserkraft
eingetreten ist dass die wasserkraft vor
dem aus steht das sagen nicht wir das
sagt der bundesverband erneuerbare
energien und wir werden das in der form
nicht akzeptieren meine damen und herren
ebenso
ebenso wird das potenzial der biomasse
nicht hinreichend genutzt der idee
kabinettsentwurf ist ein ausstiegs part
für den bestand an bioenergie anlagen
und das ist ja gar nicht falsch das ist
ja gar nicht falsch das biomethan
stärker genutzt werden sollte auch
gerade für die spitzen darf kraftwerke
aber von den 900 9000 anlagen in
deutschland können dass ihnen die
allerwenigsten und es ist doch so dass
die biomasse strom und wärme liefert
beides brauchen wir beides hilft auch
entsprechend die abhängigkeiten
insgesamt zu reduzieren biomasse biogas
könnte übrigens auch sofort mehr
produzieren könnte die abhängigkeit vom
russischen gas sofort entsprechend
minimieren aber sie wollen die biomasse
aus ideologischen gründen nicht da muss
auch schlicht nachgebessert werden und
da werden wir auch entsprechend unsere
forderungen gewicht verleihen ebenso
ebenso wird das riesige das riesige
potenzial der geothermie in keiner weise
adressiert wir brauchen auch weiter
innovationen wir brauchen technische
regelungen und auch lösungen um
entsprechen die energiewende zum erfolg
zu machen und herbigs die sprechen ja
auch häufig vom energie einsparen und
energieeffizienz ist auf jeden fall
wichtig und richtig aber es findet sich
in dem aktuellen paket überhaupt keine
einzige maßnahme um die energieeffizienz
entsprechend auch zu stärken sie
unterscheiden ist die unterscheidung
letztlich doch im geplanten oster paket
in erneuerbare erster und zweiter klasse
wind wasserkraft schlecht pv gut
biomasse schlecht dass es
kontraproduktiv auch gerade in der
jetzigen krise wir wollen alle
erneuerbaren und wir brauchen auch alle
erneuerbaren um das klar zu sagen und
letztlich
letztlich fehlt bei ihrem paket auch
eine systemische betrachtung es findet
keinerlei integration statt es herrscht
nach wie vor das motto produce ein
vergelt also zu sagen produzieren und
sich dann nicht mehr um die mengen
kümmern wir brauchen mehr anstrengungen
bei einer frage des netzausbaus
auch bei der frage der verteilnetze bei
der markt integration und bei den
speichern und all diese punkte befinden
sich übrigens nicht im überragenden
öffentlichen interesse man muss also das
richtige auch richtig machen und dafür
stehen wir wir brauchen weitere planungs
beschleunigungen es ist überhaupt keine
frage und da könnten wir doch auch mal
ein beispiel gleich lösen das ist die
frage die ausgleichsflächen für jede tv
freifläche brauchen zusätzlich
ausgleichsflächen und da bin ich das
sind jeder meinung dass wir darauf
verzichten können und wir würden da mit
einem einfachen schritt sehr vieles
vereinfachen und auch erleichtern da
eben auch unser vorschlag des
entsprechend auch auszusetzen oder
abzuschaffen
aber auch die privaten haushalte stöhnen
weiter unter den hohen energiepreisen
und deshalb braucht es auch weitere
entlastungen abschaffung der eeg-umlage
war ein richtiger schritt aber die
abschaffung der ihh die umlage kostet
den staat im moment überhaupt kein geld
wir müssen also wie stromsteuer auf das
europäische minimum senken und
insbesondere die energieintensiven
unternehmen wie oft im internationalen
wettbewerb stehen weiter entlasten sonst
wird die energiekrise zur jobkrise und
genau das wollen wir nicht wir brauchen
also eine energiewende die richtig
gemacht ist und die vor allem mit und
für die menschen gemacht ist herzlichen
dank
andreas lernens aus der unionsfraktion
und tier wird weiter diskutiert über den
ausbau erneuerbarer energien und eine
sogenannte el angel infrastruktur die
beschleunigte erstellt werden soll wir
sind aber schon beim drittletzten redner
angekommen und das ist bemerkt aus der
spd fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen die wir bürgerinnen bürger ich
bin erschüttert wie tief das niveau hier
von rechts noch sinken kann
nichtsdestotrotz sei sehr zufrieden dass
diese stimme zumindest in ein
landesparlament jetzt verstummt ist und
schleswig holstein haben sie es nicht
mehr
sagt er
herr eckert nicht verstehe auch ihre
rolle als mahner hier aber sie sind da
schon längst war weg die bundesregierung
ist schon nicht mehr beim mahnen und
beim teufel an die wand malen sondern
schon beim agieren jedenfalls was das
kurzfristige betrifft gasspeicher gesetz
lg gesetzt da sind wir schon dabei aber
wir müssen uns jetzt um die
langfristigen sachen kümmern deswegen
lassen sie mich ein bisschen die
tragweite unseres reform projektes auf
den punkt bringen was wir heute machen
dass wir heute auf den weg bringen ist
nichts geringeres als das größte
klimaschutz energiesicherheit
innovations- und zukunftspaket dieses
landes
man darf das durch mal mit diesem
partner fragen nach der dampfmaschine
dem fließband den computer der
künstliche intelligenz schaffen wir mit
diesem gesetzespaket die voraussetzungen
für das gelingen der fünften
industriellen revolution denn die
unabhängigkeit die unabhängigkeit von
kohle öl und gas der ausbau von wind-
und sonnenenergie sind nicht mehr
aufzuhalten und das ist auch gut so dass
es gut für die unabhängigkeit von
russland das ist gut für die
energiesicherheit dass es gut für den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland und das
ist gut für unsere kommunen vor allem
aber meine damen und herren ist das gut
für unsere kinder und enkelkinder und
das sind wir
kollegen den kollegen deutschland ist
das land der handwerker und ingenieure
wir führen aber deutschland jetzt heraus
aus den fossilen energien und machen es
dazu doch zu dem weltweit führenden land
der innovationen der investition und
klimaneutraler industrie und lassen sie
mich das ganze anhand von drei punkten
mal etwas verdeutlichen erstens wir
wollen 20.45 ein klimaneutrales
industrieland sein dafür werden wir
alles tun wir werden dafür sorgen dass
künftige generationen noch eine
bewohnbare erde vorfinden und weiter
ihre träume verwirklichen können das
wird uns allen und so viel ist klar viel
abverlangt aber das ist es allemal wert
klimaneutralität bis 20.45 das bedeutet
wir müssen richtig gas geben vom antrag
vom bis zum bau einer windkraftanlage
gehen in deutschland durchschnittlich 22
monate ins land nur für die planung da
muss noch gebaut werden 22 monate um das
mal zu verdeutlichen so lange tragen
elefant ihre babys aus sie können sich
ausrechnen wie lange das noch dauert bis
der strom fließt und das können wir uns
nicht mehr leisten
wir wollen runter auf die tragezeit von
rennpferden unter einem jahr muss drin
sein darum werden wir jetzt
beschleunigen und zwar am jagd galopp
meine damen und herren
diese industrielle revolution ist eine
riesenherausforderung für unsere ganze
industriegesellschaft das wissen wir
aber es ist auch eine riesige chance
lassen sie mich den unternehmen in
diesem land vom kleinsten malerbetrieb
bis zum größten it-unternehmen folgende
botschaft mit auf den weg geben ohne sie
werden wir diese energiewende nicht
schaffen nutzen sie das
innovationspotenzial nachhaltiger
technologien entwickeln forschen sie
installieren sie helfen sie uns die
transformation made in germany zum
erfolg zu machen und gemeinsam schaffen
wir die wirtschaft von morgen und neue
gute arbeitsplätze hier in deutschland
und europa und eins das kann ich ihnen
versichern diese ampel koalition wird
sie mit aller kraft dabei unterstützen
drittens
wir stärken unsere kommunen und
beteiligen sie haben ausbau der
erneuerbaren wo erneuerbare energie
erzeugt wird werden die städte und
gemeinden finanziell profitieren und
davon haben dann alle bass und jeder und
jede von uns lebt in einer kommune ist
ob selbst die fdp liegt in einer kommune
braucht mein kita-platz will gute und
sichere gehwege haben gut ausgestattete
schulen und rathäuser und auch dazu
dafür werden wir sorgen werden die
erneuerbaren einen beitrag leisten ganz
direkt vor ort und für die menschen
ihre kolleginnen kollegen mit dem oster
paket machen wir unser land fit für eine
lebenswerte und sichere innovative
zukunft dass wir kraft kosten aber wir
schaffen das wir schaffen das indem wir
aufhören darüber zu schnacken und
endlich anfangen es zu machen vielen
dank
denkt bank für die spd-fraktion und
zwischen spd-fraktion und grünen
fraktion setzt der abgeordnete stefan
seidler der mandate gewonnen schließlich
wort stein ist mitglied im
südschleswigsche wählerverband
wird also die dänische minderheit in
deutschland und ist insofern
fraktionslos weil er der einzige
abgeordnete seiner partei im bundestag
ist aber gelegentlich dafür eben jetzt
zum beispiel wenn bei uns noch einiges
voraus
dänemark gewinnt 56 prozent seiner
stromerzeugung aus wind weht und 36
35 und deutschland ist abgeschlagen mit
einem anteil von 23 prozent
norwegen ist seit 20.15 ein enormer
sprung von unter 200 watt
windenergiekapazität pro kopf auf fast
900 watt in 20 21 gelungen das zeigt
wenn der politische wille vorhanden ist
können große aufgaben gelingen
zugleich müssen aber die ökologischen
belastungsgrenzen von nord und ostsee
berücksichtigt werden dennoch reden wir
heute auch vor allem über lng das ist
hier kaum erwähnt worden und lieber herr
minister habe über robert mit dem krieg
mit diesem paket dies als besonders
umweltschonend zu verkaufen finde ich
schon ein bisschen zynisch
zu allem überfluss drohen nun
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen und
beteiligung von öffentlichkeit und
verbänden geschnitten zu werden im
schweinsgalopp die zementierung fossile
energien durchzusetzen ist ein großer
fehler es ist als würde die
bundesregierung in kutschen investieren
während draußen schon die eisenbahn
rollt steht uns wieder auf die jahre an
die fossilen zu ketten muss der ausbau
der erneuerbaren nadine im fokus stehen
damit wir die klimaziele noch erreichen
lassen wir uns dabei nicht den wind aus
den segeln nimmt dankeschön
das war schnell zwei minuten hatte
stefan seidler vom südschleswigschen
wählerverband in dieser debatte zum
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien wir
sehen inzwischen auch beim letzten
redner angekommen bei dieser beratung
das ganze wieder in den ausschüssen
weiter diskutiert werden und kommt dann
über kurz oder lang zurück ins plenum
markus hübner noch mal für die spd
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich muss das vielleicht noch mal sagen
windkraftanlagen sind keine verschmutzer
im gegensatz zur atomkraft die hier eine
fraktion immer wieder an heißt was
machen wir dann mit dem radioaktiven
müll das ist verschmutzung
wenn dieses gesetzespaket ein motto hat
dann ist es ein begriff den man in
letzter zeit häufig hört das öffentliche
interesse denn genau diesen dient es ist
im öffentlichen interesse dass wir eine
stabile energieversorgung haben denn wir
müssen uns darauf verlassen dass strom
fließt und wohnungen warm sind
es ist im öffentlichen interesse dass
wir eine nachhaltige energieversorgung
haben weil es nicht sein kann dass wir
strom und wärme auf kosten anderer
herstellen und verbrauchen
und es ist im öffentlichen interesse
dass wir eine bezahlbare
energieversorgung haben denn die
versorgung mit strom und wärme ist ein
absolutes grundbedürfnis
doch leider haben in der vergangenheit
nicht alle marktakteure das ziel einer
stabilen nachhaltigen und bezahlbaren
energieversorgung
geteilt ich spreche von den
billiganbietern die wie stromio ihre
kunden einfach im regen stehen haben
lassen
ihre praxis besteht darin kurzfristig
energie am markt einzukaufen und es sich
langfristig gegen preisschwankungen
abzusichern
solange die marktpreise steigen niedrig
bleiben ist es auch für die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher günstig
und dadurch attraktiv
der haken ist wenn die marktpreise
steigen haben wir unternehmen die
lieferungen einfach einige stellt
vielleicht ist es ein tolles
geschäftsmodell aber sicher nicht im
öffentlichen interesse
denn am ende wird es für alle teurer
kollege hilfe gestatten sie eine
bemerkung oder zwischenfrage aus der
fdp-fraktion
strom und wärme ist in ein
grundbedürfnis deswegen muss weg und
versorge das sind in der regel die
örtlichen stadtwerke
in diesen fällen eine ersatzversorgung
anbieten und zwar bisher zu den
konditionen wie in der grundversorgung
und das hat vor allem kommunale
versorger vor große herausforderungen
gestellt denn die müssen ja kurzfristig
energie zu höhere höheren preisen
einkaufen und irgendjemand muss es ja
bezahlen
etwa die bestandskunden und
bestandskunden oder die kommunen oder
der steuerzahler
das wäre nicht fair ist aber auch nicht
die menschen mit scheinbar günstigen
preisen zu locken die in wahrheit weder
stabil noch nachhaltig noch bezahlbar
sind und deswegen werden wir diese
praxis im energiewirtschaftsgesetz
ändern
zum einen stärken wir die grundversorger
die ersatzversorgung darf in zukunft das
kosten was für die energie tatsächlich
am markt bezahlt werden muss zum anderen
stärken wir aber die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher discounter dürfen in
zukunft die belieferung nicht mehr
einfach einstellen
wenn sie aus dem markt ausscheiden
wollen müssen sie das mit einem vorlauf
von drei monaten ankündigen dass meine
damen und herren ist echter
verbraucherschutz das ist der weg zu
einer stabilen nachhaltigen und
bezahlbaren energieversorgung und damit
unser aller öffentliches interesse danke
markus war das aus der spd-fraktion und
er war der letzte redner in dieser
ersten beratung von drei gesetzentwürfe
der bundesregierung die sich mit dem
ausbau erneuerbarer energien
beschäftigen und als zusatzpunkt quasi
am rande mit diskutiert wurde ein
gesetzentwurf ebenfalls der
bundesregierung da geht es um die
infrastruktur für
liquefied natural gas also dass wir sie
als verflüssigtes erdgas kämen das
erheblich leichter zu transportieren ist
als das gas weil es in einer flüssigen
form nur ungefähr 1 6 hundertstel des
volumens einnimmt als in gasförmigen
form